[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the first part of a drama
mini series called clickbait spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
the beginning of the episode shows us
andrea brewer's birthday party her
family has gathered to celebrate the
occasion her son nick daughter paya
along with nick's wife sophie get andrea
a birthday present paya is disappointed
to see that the president is a planter
when she had asked sophie to get a bread
maker instead that's gotta be the first
time in history that someone's been
upset about not getting a bread maker
she makes snarky comments to sophie
about her ideas being lame nick gets mad
at her for disrespecting his wife and
asks her to leave the party immediately
nick and sophie's sons ethan and kai
look at the adults fighting in horror
pia embarrassingly leaves and goes to a
club she drinks a lot and dances wildly
to forget what happened earlier sometime
later she is in the club's bathroom
texting a man named woody who she
matched with on a dating app she texts
him to meet her but accidentally drops
her phone in the toilet when she gets up
to flush in the following scene she is
in her apartment putting her phone in
rice so it will soak all the water and
repair itself the next day she drives to
the hospital where she works as a nurse
she is assisting a patient as he shows
her interesting videos online to keep
himself distracted in one of the videos
paya's brother nick is holding up a card
that says i abuse women he then holds up
a different card that says at 5 million
views i die he appears to be beaten and
scared as if someone is making him hold
the signs paya is shocked and doesn't
know what's going on she rushes to the
hospital's phone to call nick but the
call goes straight to voicemail she then
calls nick's wife sophie but she doesn't
pick up either paya freaks out and
rushes to nick's work she then asks his
co-worker matt about him matt claims
that he hasn't seen him since the
morning piya shows him the video which
worries matt so he asks his other
co-worker don if she has seen nick the
two find out that he missed his eight
o'clock meeting and hasn't been to work
yet paya is now more worried than ever
so she rushes to the school where sophie
teaches she barges inside even when the
guards warn her not to sophie gets rid
of the guard and watches the video
herself she is as shocked as paya to
watch it according to her nick left for
work as usual in the morning so the
video makes no sense the two then go to
the police to file a missing report on
their way the views in nick's video
reach nine thousand and proceed to
increase rapidly the case is handled by
a police detective named roshan armiri
the detective asks them several
questions about nick and focuses on the
part about him assaulting women sophie
calmly answers all his questions but
paya gets annoyed she and roshan seem to
know each other but do not act on the
fact sophie gets a call from her older
son ethan and goes back home to her
children the boys are distressed to see
the video of their father ethan is on
his tablet trying to access the find my
fam app which might show where nick is
however the app cannot find his location
because his phone is turned off the
video has reached 300 000 views in just
a few hours and everyone in the comments
is calling nick a monster sophie tells
the kids to not watch the video anymore
and to not go to school for the time
being paya returns to her apartment to
see that her phone is finally working
she finds a voicemail from nick in which
he apologizes for their fight the
previous day and says there are things
he needs to talk about with her paya
plays the voicemail on repeat while
driving to her mother andrea's house she
asks andrea if she hasn't talked to nick
that day but andrea says she hasn't paia
opts to not tell her about the situation
so she wouldn't worry just then she gets
a text from sophie asking her to come to
the police station immediately there the
two find out that another video of nick
has been uploaded to the website in this
one he holds a card that says i killed a
woman since the case has turned to
homicide detective roshan's competitive
colleague detective zach deluca is added
to investigate the case after watching
the video paya immediately recognizes
that the first two signs were in nick's
handwriting while the third one is not
luca believes that the video might be a
confession and asks the women if neck is
known to be violent an enraged sophie
tells him that nick wouldn't hurt anyone
man or woman paya also retaliates saying
nick is the victim and the detectives
should do something before the video
reaches 5 million views when sophie and
paya come out of the police station paya
shows sophie the voicemail she received
and asks her if she should show it to
the police but sophie wants to keep the
mail on the down low because nick sounds
apologetic in it which wouldn't help
their case as the police already suspect
him to be a murderer as they talk sophie
gets a call from a journalist who wants
to interview her the two get more
nervous because of the call the video
now has over a million and a half views
a nervous piya goes to her computer
genius friend vince and asks him to
somehow find next location vince says
that finding out nick's location is
beyond his reach but he has created a
subport where people from around the
world are investigating nick's case and
helping to look for him paya doesn't
believe that a mere website can find her
brother but appreciates the help anyway
after that she makes her way to nick's
house and is approached by a reporter
outside paya yells at her to stay out of
the private property and goes inside a
disappointed andrea confronts her for
keeping nick's disappearance from her
she apologizes and checks up on nick's
son ethan who seems to be calm and
playing games at this time of crisis
when paya goes back to her apartment the
video has made the news because of its
popularity suddenly her hacker friend
vince arrives with important information
the people in the subport have found out
that the video was taken in a specific
kind of delivery van by analyzing the
symbols in the background piya thanks
vince and takes the proof to the police
they begin to look for the specific van
through the traffic cameras while pai
awaits outside accompanied by nick's
co-worker matt after a while she
refreshes the website and sees that the
views have reached 5 million just then
roshan and the officers come outside
claiming that they have found the van
everyone quickly rushes to the location
with a swat team only to find that the
van is empty they search around the area
but find nothing at last the police
conclude that neck was not in the van
when it was disposed of back at the
police station luca assigns tasks to all
the officers involved in the case but
excludes roshan because he is not from
the homicide department and his services
are no longer needed when roshan tries
to retaliate luka asks him to accompany
sophie to her home outside her house
sophie is mobbed by the reporters roshan
escorts her inside to see that the house
is being investigated for evidence
several police officers spread around
looking for any significant clue they
can find the kids ask sophie if nick has
been found and she assures them that he
will be back soon just then luca arrives
at the house and seizes all the family
members phones so that they can extract
data that can potentially help them with
the case the family is skeptical about
the procedure saying that they are being
treated as suspects everyone hands their
phone over except for pia who says that
hers is at her apartment because it is
broken amidst the search paya goes out
to smoke roshan follows behind her for a
chat as the two talk we find out they
have been chatting with each other
through a dating app for a long time in
fact before piya's phone dropped in the
toilet she was planning to meet roshan
she asks him to keep her in the loop
with anything that happens with the case
however roshan reveals he has been
removed from it because he is from the
missing persons department he suggests
pair request the sergeant to put him on
the case and paya agrees
later roshan is searching the house on
his own when he sees ethan in his room
with a tablet ethan says that it was his
father's old tablet that no one uses
anymore roshan still asks for it to see
if it has something important on it but
ethan insists that he needs it to
monitor the search he explains that
nick's case has grown so popular that
people have established an app called
geo-nicking dedicated to his search in
the app people go around areas in the
city where nick can potentially be found
and search for him the areas that have
already been searched are marked off the
map in red this peaks roshan's interest
and he takes the tablet for himself he
then goes to the police station and
shows the app to the sergeant but she is
not in favor of involving the civilians
in the search roshan also shows her the
text messages that were extracted from
ethan's phone where he talks about a big
fight between his parents when roshan
walks outside of the sergeant's office
detective luca condescendingly asks him
to go home roshan then makes his way to
a site that hasn't been searched through
geonecking and finds two teenagers
searching for next body with no progress
roshan visits the mosque and then his
home his parents had seen him in the
news earlier and are proud of him for
working on such a big case they ask him
when he is going to be promoted to the
homicide department but roshan dismisses
the question the following day sophie
makes an official statement to the
reporters asking next kidnappers not to
hurt him later paya asks roshan to meet
her alone in his car and shows him the
voice message nick had left her before
his disappearance roshan is annoyed with
her for not providing them with the
information sooner but paya defends
herself by saying they can go through
her phone now he asks her what problem
nick wanted to talk to her about but
paya doesn't know either roshan then
goes to the sergeant and tells her about
the new found information he also comes
clean of his relationship with paya
before nick's disappearance after that
he returns back to his desk only to find
the pictures from his dating profile
pasted all over his station luca laughs
at him for it an enraged roshan blames
him for being discriminatory towards him
because of his religion but luka claps
back saying that roshan is not a team
player and is using this case to get
promoted the next day nick's bike is
found by the side of a secluded road the
police rush there and investigate the
scene soon an empty syringe is found
nearby they conclude that it was used to
kidnap nick after the investigation
roshan goes to sophie's home and is
received by her mother ruby he informs
the family about nick's bike being found
and asks to speak to sophie in private
he asks her about nick's voicemail to
paya to which she reveals about their
fight the night prior then roshan
inquires if sophie and nick were facing
some marital issues before his
disappearance sophie unsettled by the
question claims that the status of their
relationship has nothing to do with
nick's disappearance roshan gets
suspicious and directly asks her if she
knows where her husband is sophie looks
at him in disbelief and asks him to get
out of the house
next he goes to paya's apartment to find
her observing the geo-nicking app he
asks her about her fight with nick only
to be dismissed eventually she tells him
that she and neck are closer than most
siblings but he had been acting
differently for the last few months they
got in a fight because she called him
out on it she also reveals that on march
16th he came to her with bruises and
told her to keep it a secret from sophie
as they talk the geo-nicking app shows
nick's body has been found roshan and
paya quickly rushed to the location
where a crowd of people surround nick's
body however getting closer to it they
see that the body is just a mannequin
with nick's face pasted on it as a joke
after the incident roshan drops paya off
at her apartment where nick's co-worker
matt is waiting for her outside she and
matt go inside as roshan drives away at
night the detective uses the find my fam
app to look where nick was on the 16th
of march he finds out he was at a bar
and visits the owner the following day
while watching the cctv footage he sees
that nick had gotten into a fight with
an unknown man that day
later he calls paya to the police
station and shows her the video of the
fight pia size and relief that they
finally have a lead and thanks roshan
for working hard on the case after pile
leaves roshan presents his idea about
the geo-nicking to luca who dismisses
him at first but agrees to go on a
search anyway they reach the woods by an
abandoned road where roshan finally
finds next decaying dead body in a
nearby river in the following scene we
see roshan walk up to paya in her
apartment and inform her of the dead
body being found even though paya had
anticipated this she breaks down crying
on the floor mourning her brother's
death
the next day roshan is welcomed into the
police station with applause the
sergeant promotes him to the homicide
department and even luca praises him for
his good work he then helps his
co-worker to go through sophie's socials
while working roshan notices a picture
of sophie with a man who looks like the
guy nick got into a fight with at the
bar a surprised roshan rechecks and
confirms that it is the same man in the
following scene we see sophie at the
police station roshan officially informs
her of her husband's death she freezes
on hearing the news and asks the
detective how he died luca reveals that
he had head trauma but the cause of
death hasn't been confirmed yet she
sheds a single tear and asks them who
was responsible luca then shows her the
footage of nick's fight with the man and
asks sophie if she knows him to their
surprise she lies and says she doesn't
then she is shown a picture of them
together so sophie finally admits that
the man is her former colleague named
curtis hamilton she claims they are just
friends and co-workers but after her
first lie the detectives find it hard to
believe later she returns home and sits
all of her family down she finally
reveals to the kids that their father is
not returning home all of them burst
into tears grieving nick's death
then we see paya at the police station
demanding roshan to let her see her
brother's body however she is not
allowed to see him until the postmortem
back in the house sophie tells her
mother that she was asked about curtis
by the police when she reveals that she
referred to him as just a friend her
mother looks at her in disbelief it is
clear that something was going on
between the two sophie cries saying that
if curtis is the one who killed nick it
will be her fault as they talk paya
arrives at the house asking if she can
sleep for the night sophie invites her
but doesn't tell her anything about
curtis then we are shown a flashback of
nick and sophie's last wedding
anniversary they had a party that they
enjoyed to the fullest but by the end of
it sophie received a text from curtis
that said he could not stop thinking
about her sophie's demeanor changed
after seeing the text that night she
came clean about her three-month affair
with curtis nick was furious at her back
in the present day sophie sneaks out of
the house and goes to see curtis he is
shocked to see her but invites her in he
acknowledges everything happening in
sophie's life and asks her if she is
fine sophie instead asks him why he met
nick without telling her curtis replies
that nick messaged him out of the blue
and asked him to meet at the bar he
wanted curtis to tell him every detail
of their relationship who was interested
first when did they meet each other and
how many times they made love he claims
that by the end of the conversation nick
attacked him but sophie is suspicious of
him as they talk the police knock on his
door and arrest curtis it turns out they
had been following sophie after she lied
about her relationship earlier both
curtis and sophie are then taken to the
police station as suspects of nick's
murder subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching